passive versus active main character
mm-hmm what's okay passive versus this
is an opportunity situation because most
people assume and most movies are about
somebody who's active and they got to do
something but there are successful
pictures where you have someone who's
not and how do those work that's that's
what you look for you say well everybody
says do this and this one doesn't but it
still works so why what they do that
that compensate it for it because
obviously if you have an active main
character it's easy to watch you're
gonna see whether they get what they
want or not and it's all taken care of
but what about that well what you'll see
is there still has to be conflict as
long as there's conflict you'll be okay
because the conflict will will create
the suspense and the tension that
sustains us if you're using dramatic
tension as the main tool not all movies
do there are like ensemble pieces that
we'll be following a bunch of different
stories of different characters and the
unifying element is Amelia like diner
it's about a diner it's what happens in
a diner and as long as it's understood
by the audience that that's what they're
watching you know you can signal that
that's what it's about in fact that
movie there's a 1982 picture I believe
the opening title is like a week before
Christmas 1959 or something like that
maybe 1958 and then it's about the
Baltimore Colts and all this stuff but
it gives you a sense right away from the
opening it's gonna take place in about a
week okay I think it actually starts
Christmas Eve and it's gonna take it
takes place in a week okay so that
frames it and then you have an ensemble
people and there there's dramatic
conflicts within those but the overall
picture doesn't and have doesn't utilize
dramatic tension as offense the main
tool so you don't have that you have
first acts of all the different
characters and the different subplots
and each subplot has its own act
structure generally there are a couple
that kind of dangle off and disappear
but most of them the main ones do but if
we go back to the main the most common
form which is character with a jack
there's obstacles the an active one
helps but there was a famous editor I
was told about and I don't remember who
it was who said the secret to the craft
is that all scenes are either chases or
escapes thief there's somebody trying to
get something or trying to avoid
something and a passive character can be
somebody who's just trying to avoid
something and the key is to build a
circumstance where that's hard like the
Lars and the real girl talked about that
this is a movie whether you have a
passive main character is just wants to
all he wants to do it's an escape story
because the whole town is united to try
to not let him do what he wants to do by
the very indirect means playing along
with them but you can see the tension as
there is that surrounds the question is
is he ever going to get better so there
that would be a passive main character
or I like Cuckoo's Nest what does this
guy want to do he wants to avoid doing
work he wants to play cards doesn't any
agenda beyond that but the way the story
is constructed he's placed in the worst
possible situation for his unique
characteristics which is that he's he's
a noble person who wants to help people
you know but he has an opportunity he's
and and this world crushes him so that
that's something you can look for a
graduate I think sorry the Graduate is
right he doesn't have to pursue her I do
have an analysis of the Graduate in the
book he doesn't have to pursue her she's
in his laughs nothing there but it what
keeps us suspended there is actually
that's not an escape movie it's dramatic
irony so you look at the middle part of
that this example of a movie where the
second act is actually not that long
it's about equal size with the first and
third acts the second act is about will
he get caught and you have combat guy
earn a comic irony played with where and
sometimes dramatic irony where the
mother inquires we'd go every night he
you know he cuts himself while shaving
you can see he's not comfortable and so
you know I just drive or in the hotel
where everybody recognizes him he's with
the girl and
the Catherine but Ross the actress she's
with me later
oh yeah and at the hotel where he's been
having these liaisons and everybody
knows him
and he's trying to conceal from her what
what was happening so that's one the
Sunset Boulevard is a movie about a guy
who's trying to hustle this older woman
he's writer he's trying to hustle her
and after a certain point really from
the mid middle of the movie on he's he's
very passive he's he's just it's kind of
avoiding the world so but that's it's an
escape and that way he's trying to just
stay away from everything and the world
intrudes but largely that one is
sustained by a little bit of tension
about someone trying to not let him
escape
and voiceover narration which keeps us
it's a form of telegraphing you know
this is about to happen or little did I
know this would happen that kind of
thing so that we're anticipating so
that's the so the answer the question
can you have a passive main character
we'll look for where the conflicts are
if the character is passive never wants
to do anything can you put them in a
situation that challenges that and makes
them fight
you